[Music]
all right Heather we are aiming at your
closet we're finally in the house here
you are only this right only this room
there's a little peek inside we should
have a toast them yes you pulled out the
shams I do I like it welcome we're gonna
get any debt housewives okay yeah let's
do so we are we have put season 11
behind us
bye-bye the reunion is over yes how do
you feel after watching all three parts
of the reunion it didn't go exactly how
I thought I thought it was shocking whoo
really there was a couple people that
were real smug then couldn't own up to
anything and I just felt like they had
been wrong so anything they had done had
been away I don't know I felt I thought
it was odd you should be kissing
Shannon's acid begging her that she made
me out like a con woman and a liar and I
didn't lie I didn't go out and catch him
someone that was very ugly you're saying
Vicki can come back from this last
season Vicki is like you know I'd like
that you know the character bit and
horror movies that you keep killing and
they keep getting like like Jason yeah
no but Vicki just comes back yeah just
she just keeps going back Wow get off my
show but my Felucia boat this is my show
okay Larry here's how I know where I am
with Vicki is that weird here's the
thing about me and Vicki we are not
close friends we are really nice
acquaintances and that's it
she has not come to the closet yet no do
you want to come back will you come back
if they asked me back I I would assume
I'd probably say yes but I have to say
given the climate of what's going on
with the cast I would probably have to
think about it a little bit yeah
everybody wants to come back I don't
know I I'm telling you it fluctuates
every day that's what I'm saying like my
knee-jerk reaction it's I absolutely
would love to come back for Season 12 it
love for it
I feel like you know I want the fans of
the show to see our house feel like you
know you've all built it with us and
then you want to take a tour with us
you know we have a lot of stuff going
you look for Santa's new youtube channel
I'm excited to share that with everyone
but you know the the off season
shenanigans that are going on makes me a
little uncomfortable